[MUSIC PLAYING]
JÉSSICA OSORIO OLIVA:
Hi, I'm Jéssica Osorio.
I'm a journalist and communication
specialist from Guatemala.
I have completed the course, Remote
Work Revolution for Everyone.
The course made a very
interesting professional turn
for me and my professional team.
I have been working
remotely the last six years
but the knowledge that I got
through this Harvard Online course
allowed me to organize my
time based on my well-being
to reduce the possibility
of making mistakes.
The reason why I tried to
complete the certificate
and finally be part of the Harvard
global community of learners
was that I needed improve my
skills, and because of the pride
of having the support of one of
the best universities in the world.
Thank you, Harvard Online.
[MUSIC PLAYING]